when the Lord says that the kingdom of
God belongs to children and that you
must be converted and accept the kingdom
as a child because they are great in the
Kingdom what I see here that God in his
love and compassion and mercy views
children not condemned original guilt
condemned because of the Adam sin of
Adam and Eve but in a state of Innocence
under his grace and mercy and that even
if they're not born to Christians homes
where they're baptized the Lord views
them and a state of grace and grants
them to enter on the merits of Christ
this what you're asking me just from
scripture because what I see in
scripture I'm going to give you the
verses you can read them later because
I've done sessions on this is that up
until an age specific age and the Bible
doesn't have an age because it varies
from Individual to individual some
people mature and develop faster than
others but the Bible is clear that there
are those who are not able to discern
their right from their left right and
wrong Deuteronomy 1: 29 39 Deuteronomy 1
29-39 specifically verse 39 if you read
it God says that first generation did
not enter the promised land all of that
group with the exception of Joshua Caleb
died in the desert he says your children
who are now no longer children they're
now grown they entered why read
Deuteronomy 139 for me 139 yes and the
little ones that you said will be taken
captives
your your children would not yet know
good from bad they will enter the land I
will give it to them
why because they don't know good from
bad so you mean these children were so
young they didn't know difference right
or wrong and God didn't hold them
accountable yeah that's a great Point
yeah okay that's theonomy 139 right yep
now go to Jonah 4:1 why did God not
destroy the ninevites Jonah 411 read
vers 10 to 11 10 to 11 but the Lord said
you have been concerned about this plant
though you do not tend you did not did
not tend it or make it grow it sprang up
overnight and died overnight a should I
have not have concern for the great city
of nin in which there there are more
than
120,000 people who cannot tell their
right hand from their left and also many
animals so why did God want to spare not
destroy ninev because they didn't know
the right from the left right so 12,000
they know the difference between right
and left right right yeah isn't that
clear that God looks at the condition of
a person and sees if this person is not
mature enough to discern the will of God
he will not condemn them but view them
in Mercy and love and
grace that's John 411 right yeah yeah
now go to Isaiah 75- 16 about the
Messianic child
15- 16 yeah Isaiah 715 to6 talking about
the Messianic child that even Jesus born
as a child in his human existence in his
human mind and Consciousness the God man
he too will have to experience human
development this is about the
Incarnation this is about Jesus as God
In the Flesh Jesus became a true human
being not a human person we're not
historians that is
blasphemy Jesus became a human being one
Divine person he took on genuine human
nature he experienced genuine human
limitations and he went through growth
like all humans do from a baby to a
todder to an adolescent and through
those stages he grew and learned because
he's not just God he's the God man it
says about Jesus that he too right will
be so
young
that in that condition and State
he will not know right and wrong but
when he matures enough to know right and
wrong he'll always choose the right over
the wrong this is here Isaiah 7156 I'm
not making it
up he will be eating Curts and on when
he knows enough to reject the wrong and
choose the right when he knows enough
Isaiah 7:15 to 16 read it again yeah 15
he would be eating curds and honey when
he knows enough to reject the wrong and
choose the right for before the boy
knows enough to reject the wrong and
choose the boy knows
enough the land of the two kings you
dread will be laid waste now how do we
know about Jesus because of verse 14 is
talking about the Virgin birth read
Isaiah 7:14 so who's this
child therefore the Lord himself will
give you a sign the Virgin will conceive
and give birth to a son and will call
him Emanuel so Jesus the Virgin born
baby Emanuel also will have to grow to
know the difference between right and
wrong wow okay right passage yeah all
right now let me give you one more from
Paul one more from Paul listen to this
this is scripture don't believe the
calvinist and their damnable heresy the
Bible does talk about children being too
young to know the difference and God not
holding them accountable but viewing
them in Mercy and Grace don't let these
Bible perverts tell you otherwise like
they deceived me until the Lord showed
me otherwise go to Romans 7 verses 7-2
7 to 12 yeah Romans 7: 7- 12 what shall
we say then is the law sful certainly
not nevertheless I will not have known
what sin was had it not been for the law
for I would not have known what coveting
really was if the law had not said you
should not covet but sin seizing the
opportunity afforded by the Commandment
produced in me every kind of coting for
apart from the law sin was dead wait
wait listen what he says when there is
no law sin is dead in you are you guys
listen what Paul is saying Romans 77 to2
when there is no law sin is dead in you
meaning your flesh has a sinful
inclination sinful Tendencies but it's
dormant in you when does sin spring to
life when does sin come to life and then
causes you to sin when you become aware
of the law because what did he say apart
from the law what for apart from the law
sin was dead now listen to what Paul
says at one time he was alive once I was
alive apart from the law but when the
Commandment came sin sprang to life and
I died I found die when the law came to
him so wait Paul says that he was alive
at one
time but then to him when God revealed
the Commandment to Paul and Paul became
aware of the Commandment that's when
came to life and caused Paul to break
the command and die wow
okay did you catch it yeah so if we take
the Bible children though born with a
sinful tendency they're not dead are
they yeah because they don't know the
law right so they're alive yeah they're
alive yeah so when do they die when the
law comes to them when they become of
the law right yeah yeah and that's when
they break it and die you guys see why I
say if I go with scripture
all children no matter if they're
Buddhist family they're under the mercy
and grace of God that's why I believe
when children die the Lord brings them
into his presence because they're under
his mercy and Grace and love and covered
by his blood it's what I believe by
children because I see in scripture as
far as what the Orthodox I don't know
and I don't know what the father said I
know
Augustine again I'm just being honest
Augustine is not one of my favorite
theologians I'm just being honest with
you guys I don't hate him and I know
he's a saint and the Orthodox Catholic
church and he's called blessing the
Orthodox I don't hate the man and he's
great but he did teach some things that
really trouble me like the
predestination that became the precursor
to Calvinism I can't stand that and I
know there are statements in which he
says unbaptized infants go to
hell i h i I don't know man I I have
hard time with that but anyway I'm not
aware that this is a consensus view or
the majority of view prior after
Augustine but my point is if you just
tell me from scripture here scripture
right now finish it to 12 by the way to
12 yeah
yeah I found that the very Commandment
that was intended to bring life actually
brought dead for sin seizing the
opportunity afforded by the Commandment
deceived me and and through the
Commandment put me to death so then the
law is did he die when was he put to
death when he receiv received the
Commandment again so but he said I was
alive because I didn't know about the
Commandment right yeah but when he was
mature enough to realize hey God exists
I'm part of the Covenant Community
there's a law that's When sin made him
break it and he died yeah but now let me
refute an a possible objection so so
okay well if children are born with a
sinful proclivity but they're not dead
and God views them with love and
compassion mercy and they're covered by
the mercy of the Lord and if they die
the Lord brings them into his presence
glory be his name God of infinite love
then why baptize them exactly especially
early why there is this to baptizm let
me explain why then baptize them well
did you know early on you second century
there were Christians who delayed the
baptism of their infants that was
allowed let me explain that you'll find
Teran mentioning he wasn't a father but
he mentions the practice of the church
there were parents who
delayed the baptism of infants because
they wanted the infants to get baptized
after they had committed some sin to be
forgiven of so number one what does that
tell you it tells you that the universal
teaching of the church without exception
the universal teaching of the church
without exception is water baptism is
used by the Holy
Spirit to bring about your forgiveness
of sins and make you alive because
that's when the spirit comes upon you
and makes you one with Christ so they
thought hold on if water baptism removes
sins let's wait for them to to be a
little older so if they sin they can be
baptized and forgiven so people actually
delayed it and at that time Christians
would allow that they did allow it it
became stricter as time went on but
Protestants you understand what that
means right it means that there was no
one in the early church nobody notada
even Heretics believe water baptism was
used by the Holy Spirit to make you
alive and forgive your sins because it
was at the act of water baptism Spirit
came and United you to Christ so this is
why they delayed it all right well now
churches are strict and they say no you
got to B infants well why they're not
spiritually dead because it is that
baptism that unites them to Christ and
makes them part of the
body so if you want your infant to be
part of the spiritual body he or she
must be baptized because if they're not
baptized they are not part of the
spiritual body of Christ so what
Christians do is to make them part of
the spiritual body of Christ they
baptize them and then later on catechize
them and or prepare them for the
Christian Life and then when they sin
they confess and are restored so this is
the logic and by the way glory to the
Holy Spirit I want to give him the glory
no praise to me I started thinking about
this because what what did I say about
apologetics you have to be a spiritual
chess player you have to think 50 to 200
moves ahead of your opponent so I was
thinking hold on if I was a Protestant
anti Catholic this is what I would say
to me now and so how do I respond so
glory to the holy spirit for working in
us working in me in such a way where I
anticipating the objections to help you
obliterate these objections